No shortage of fodder
for the late night host
after what happened here on Capitol
Hill yesterday
when Kevin McCarthy made history
as the first lawmaker
in a hundred years to be denied
the speaker's gavel after just o
As McCarthy watched ballot
after ballot after ballot fail,
he sat there in the House
chamber at
times laughing,
looking amused or whispering
to a senior aide sitting next to
But while McCarthy appeared to l
laugh it off in front of the cam
he is facing a real threat
from the divisions
within his own party
when it comes to the second bid
for House speaker.
The last time
McCarthy wanted to be speaker,
he bowed out before
the voting get even started.
We should put this conference fi
and I think there's something to
for us to unite.
We probably need a fresh face.
I'll stay on as majority leader.
But the one thing I found in
talking to everybody,
if we are going to unite and be
we need a new face to help do th
So nothing more than that.
That was 20. 15.
This is now.
McCarthy is vowing to fight
until he secures the job
I think at the end of the day,
we'll get everybody
saying that you failed three tim
How do you possibly pull this of
and get two to 18
the hours of action
or really inaction on Capitol Hi
yesterday continued to drag on
as lawmakers
braced for a long night of negot
in the Capitol after they adjour
Ordering in pizza here, as you c
being wheeled into McCarthy's of
they continued to meet
behind closed doors
McCarthy
started.
that was just one of the many mo
that stood out yesterday.
McCarthy not paying
close attention
when it was the time for him
to vote for himself in the third
Of votes.
There was
another curious moment yesterday
though, as cameras in the chambe
were trained on members
as they were going back and fort
while this voting was happening.
Democratic Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
was spotted chatting
with the Republican, Paul Gosar.
The lawmaker was ties
to white nationalists
and remember, was censured
after he posted that altered ani
depicting him
killing AOC and President Biden.
Does anyone in this chamber
find this behavior acceptable?
Would you allow depictions of vi
against women, against colleague
Would you
would you allow that in your hom
Do you
think that should happen
on a school board?
In a city council,
in a church
And if it's not acceptable there
why should it be accepted here?
A spokesman for Alexandria Ocasi
told CNN
that Gosar was asking her
if any Democrats
were planning to vote present.
That's a tactic that's been disc
so McCarthy could leave a lower
that he needed to overcome
Also yesterday,
Jorge Santos had a hard
landing in Washington on his fir
The Republican congressman elect
who has admitted to making
many false claims about his back
and largely has hidden from repo
or only spoken to conservative o
since that news
broke, was unable to do
so when he was here
on Capitol Hill yesterday.
He was seen sitting alone in the
sometimes checking
his phone
as fellow New York Republicans
were openly criticizing him,
saying that his conduct is embar
listen.
His conduct is embarrassing
and unbecoming
and it is certainly a distractio
Of course,
one of the pitfalls from yesterd
is that new
members were not actually sworn
because there was no House speak
Jorge Santos is one of those, th
His campaign website
did say later on that he was swo
Of course,
the members
who may have had the worst time
here are the family members
or those of lawmakers
who brought their families here
to Washington
thinking they were going to be s
but instead you saw
sleeping kids
in the chamber
as the McCarthy speaker fight
was playing out.
Bored children there, as you can
in the in the aisles.
Some of them
maybe wish they were in school
after all,
because of the hours of speeches
that were going on.
Of course, today
the House is expected to hold an
of voting potentially.
We are waiting to see what happe
Democrats have really been revel
in the Republican disarray,
saying they are bringing popcorn
for today.